I'm really excited so currently I'm
actually going to be a rising Junior at
Washington University in St Louis so
I've been here in the summer doing
research at the med school so I've been
accustoming myself to the Heat and I'm
really excited just to play in this
tournament it feels great it's my first
time in St Louis actually ever so uh
it's really exciting and I'm excited to
play
um it feels great to be back to like see
like people who haven't seen like so
long and to just play more chess again
and so this is such a nice city so
well this tournament is obviously really
big really prestigious so I'm really
honored to be here and also happy as
well I'm hoping to improve my result
from last year it feels nice um coming
back here again
I look forward to this tournament
literally every single year it's like
probably my favorite Tournament of the
year so
um great of course because this event
um ever since I was younger I always
wanted to play in it so now I'm finally
here and I'm really excited
oh it feels great everyone here has been
so nice to me I love how the St Louis
chess club treats the its players
I've been here once before that was for
a chess camp and I know they've done a
lot of changes since then so I am really
happy to be here it's pretty awesome I
was here last year to do so well so I'm
excited to have another chance to play
here against all these amazing people
and it's just a really nice venue too so
very excited to be here overall I'm
excited it's um I actually don't know
how many times I've played this
tournament but it's probably my last
time this year I think because I'm
getting too old now
um but it's good to be back I'm excited
to play if you're really great this is
one of my favorite tournaments to play
in
um I played in person for the past this
is my third year now and uh to be able
to like play against such strong uh
young female counterparts is always a
really great
um scene and also being in St Louis it's
always like a really fun experience so
I'm really excited for this tournament
and I hope that will go well
[Music]